[Applause]
uh over here kind of this half of this
half what would you like to hear a
freestyle
did you see nipples on the beach
nipples on the beach in santa pay so
beautifully specific but i'm becoming
aroused right now
it's like wow nipples on the beach in
santa pay there was someone else at the
same time said something
called baits
combines
as in combine harvesters
yeah cool but you're so intimately
connected with them that you just call
them combines is that is that what
they're meant to be called people in are
you all farmers this is an agricultural
day trip hey combines
what do you own a combine
you wish you did
what
surely they're very expensive right
actually they're like these like big
investments that's the problem
this is the saddest story ever
who wished he owned a combine a combined
harvester for
know this is fantastic nipples on the
beach in santa pay a man who wishes he
owned a con man that's all he wants in
the world let's come to these people
here yeah you just put a hand up they're
so polite yes
an english
[Music]
an english morris dancer practicing in
the cotswolds i love him and let's come
to the kind of this section this is the
fourth suggestion what's it going to be
often
wearing flip flops thank you
i can tell you've all been on the booth
morris are in the cotswolds practicing
puffing wearing flip-flops a man who
wishes to come back harvested nipples on
the beach in santa fe so far these
suggestions are absolutely exquisite i'm
really excited to wrap it up i want one
final one doesn't come from anywhere
just just make it one you're proud
the crown princes of hell one of them
hit one of the satanic majesties just
just in case you don't know there's a
couple of other ones as well uh yes i
was a bit of a goth as a teenager
great um this is great this is what
we're going to do dj do you want to do
me a favor and drop me that beat this is
a freestyle that is a wrap made up on
the spot based entirely on suggestions i
get the vibe that you thought were just
going to get the suggestions and walk
away like no way is he doing this no
it's about all those topics and don't
worry it won't be anywhere near as
atrociously [ __ ] as you're expecting it
to be
i'm very thrilled to do this
i want one thing there in my mind every
night going to bed praying for a
combined heart disturbed my heart for
sure i'm like oh save money starting
there i put a little bit of coin in the
back ever so aroused by the convincer
when i have a rank like oh yes injury in
a dress go into the field and it starts
to threaten i thrash it why cause i want
to go to the back left please will you
give me a lawn and they're like no no
you ain't too high for the combine so
that long's denied the still i'm gonna
go there big on the street i'm a farmer
agricultural tree please will you let me
have a go if this is a john deere i
don't want to know i'll be riding up
there in the field gathering the corn
you can see all of the yield right there
in the back i will give that crap dog
basically i wanna be that farmer no
dairy no other things just get done and
i start with the gathering rotating all
the crops i really hope one day the day
you're right doc you'll be there when
you're throwing with a wide brim hat
combine harvester yeah it's that we're
still rapping about this topic i'm on
the beach over there and i do spot it
i've got a bulge in my pocket around
today because i see ladies in sandra pay
i know you didn't put the gender in the
middle olivia could see a man on the
beach with a nipple out there yeah
that's my fancy man post on instagram
and they don't even run don't take it
down they're like i love that your
skin's white but you need to be proud
that they're different a high shoulder
what's the name of the video like
alphonse that's the goalkeeper in the
epl if you've got your nipples out then
it's swell topless on the beach i guess
see a sexy french lady she undressed it
feels so natural when they're there
[Music]
[Music]
of oxford where did they do it i'm not
really sure say a bad word about the
ancient dance wearing all white well
shirt what do they do they get a little
stick can they kick it you're [ __ ]
fools go and play cricket basically
that's what they start doing they're
practicing a weird dance that they're
pursuing i'm zooming in yes it's up for
discussion edinburgh zoo i could check
out those puffins big feet with a tiny
little color i want struggle to walk any
like the other he's moving along in the
hip hop
[Music]
do you understand this is what you came
out produce with your hand you're like
yo rap about the little word ever so
weird ever so absurd now the last one
thus for blood and the crown prince of
hell be elves above and an evil demon in
your mind if you read that book lord off
the flies they worship me all those
little kids be else above get down to
the pig but let me say this more from
the poor after a long day of just
pulling eyes out on stalks i love to
relax i write myself
what do i do when i relax and hold like
a candle make all of the bubbles with
foam and what do you see when the foam
parts are little i plc
tickles